anytime I want to mock my cousin's in  India I just turn on the faucet and  drink up  how are you gonna do me good  what is this one family mom your brother  yeah what girl already knows what's  coming  so that's your so you [ __ ] up mess up  seeing that a lot saying those eggs a  lot of white girls with Bravo guys  that's I know it's tech money you  [Applause]  if you got a pretty girl what do you do  but you make money man you know how you  don't you make a lot of money if she  married you with that dick as Indian  she does gulia  oh yeah which you gotta be the first  danger then something she does not work  in America  I hope Indian girls won't date using  Indian accent huh you talk too much  you said yours  I Big Bang Theory the zoo  [Music]  okay  [Applause]  just not making a home  [Music]  we know this guy